اكيد انا تحت الرقابه والحمايه الامنيه
منذ بضع اشهر لانه
حياتي مهدده كما تم اعلامي من وزاره
الداخليه
تهديدات مباشره
هي وزاره الداخليه رات ان التهديدات التي
وصلتني هي تهديدات جديه
من الحمايه
من اجل من انت محميه
العديد من
انا انا اعتقد وليس معناها جديد لكن اعتقد
ان هناك
المتشددين من حركه النهضه
وراء تهديد سلامه سلامه في هذا الملف الذي
يرونهم انهم
كشف
ورط العديد من قياداتهم مثل الحبيب اللوز
وغيره من القيادات النضويه
فاليوم هو الملف هذايا كشف تورط قيادات
كبيره من حركه النهضه الرجل الاول والثاني
والثالث بعد درجه الغنوشي والعديد من
القيادات
نقول لهم الامن الموازي وغيره وهناك بعض
الحقائق في هذا الملف الحقائق التي
ترعب لانه هناك اختراق لامن الدوله
وارتباط هذا الملف ايضا
بملفات اخرى
كالاختيالات
والعمليه الارهابيه التي حدثت في ذلك
الوقت